[Musique]
les essentiels du
Sénat énergie quel stockage pour
demain dans le contexte de la transition
énergétique le stockage de l'énergie
devient un enjeu grandissant
l'opexte l'Office parlementaire
d'évaluation des choix scientifiques et
technologique appelle à développer et
soutenir la recherche consacrée à ces
différentes technologies de stockage les
solutions de stockage électrochimique
par exemple nous y avons déjà recours au
quotidien pensons à l'électricité
embarquée dans nos smartphones ou dans
les véhicules électriques avec la
transition énergétique nos façons de
produire et d'utiliser l'énergie change
avec moins d'énergie fossile et plus
d'énergie verte nous devons trouver
comment mieux stocker l'énergie ce qui
est essentiel pour l'équilibre entre ce
que nous produisons et ce que nous
consommons en
électricité pexte a confié à Gérard
leeul député et Gérard Longuet sénateur
l'actualisation d'une note de 2019 sur
le stockage de l'électricité afin d'y
inclure les derniers développements
scientifiques et technologiques et de
comparer les solutions avant tout la
note fait un état des lieux des diverses
formes de stockage de l'énergie qui
existe aujourd'hui le stockage mécanique
qui inclut le pompage hydraulique et qui
est le plus courant le stockage
électrochimique qui concerne les
batteries le stockage électromagnétique
le stockage chimique par vecteur ou
encore le stockage thermique d'ici 2030
des batteries lithiumon plus
performantes et durbl seront disponibles
sur le marché les chercheurs explorent
également des alternatives au lithium
comme le sodium ou le potassium
réduisant la dépendance au matériaux RAR
et coûteux mais surtout les batteries du
futur intégreront de plus en plus
souvent électronique et intelligence
artificielle pour être optimisé en
comparant les modes de stockage de de
l'énergie les auteurs de la note
scientifique ont conclu que leur
pertinence dépendait de leurs usages la
solution miracle en matière de stockage
de l'énergie n'existe pas il n'existe
que des technologies de stockage
adaptées à telle ou telle situation à
privilégé au terme d'une analyse
multicritère un choix large de
technologie est donc un atout indéniable
insistent les rapporteurs par exemple
les batteries sont idéales pour un usage
de court terme tandis que l'hydrogène
est plus adapté pour une durée d' moins
une semaine il est donc souhaitable de
veiller à disposer d'un grand nombre
d'options technologiques et à
diversifier les modes de Stockage en
fonction de la chaîne de valeur des
réseaux d'énergie de la production aux
usages en passant par le transport et la
distribution préconise
l'opexte aussi il peut être pertinent
d'articuler les technologies pour les
rendre complémentaires par exemple
d'interconnecter des batteries avec des
super condensateur ou avec des volants à
inerc qui sont deux autres dispositifs
de stockage la France présente
l'avantage d'être positionné sur la
plupart de ces technologies
elle doit continuer à soutenir la
recherche pour développer des solutions
innovant et adapté à notre contexte
énergétique appelle de SVE l'office
parlementaire en
conclusion pour en savoir plus consultez
le site Internet du
Sénat